call it what are you gonna happen
anything can [ __ ] have you can have I
could get up and plant my left foot in
on the bridge of your nose and not hey
into that oh and not that ugly a stupid
[ __ ] medieval grandfather clock that
you have for some reason oh why do you
have that you don't come into my studio
and start threatening physical stuff
because I'll tell you something right
now yeah well right now yeah right now
right okay
you come at me yeah yeah yeah what's
gonna happen I don't know what's gonna
happen but I do know one thing for sure
right you know for sure that I'm gonna
I'm gonna me don't fall asleep don't do
that mmm that's very disrespectful wait
look at this if you do you know what
that is what that's me in deep REM sleep
dreaming of you trying to come out not
agreement of it wait hold on this is
what I look like when I'm asleep and I'm
dream see out here I'm gonna show it to
you again
ready this is how I've severe sleep
apnea already
then this is me not breathing for a
minute and a half and then here's the
part where I dream are you ready and
then it goes getting purple no oxygen
definitely having a stroke watch the
world record from Will Sasso two minutes
18 seconds no oxygen and then more
dreaming you get the picture
oh my god so how am I going about what
would happen if I came at you I don't
know what would happen will I but if you
come at me
I know one thing 100% for sure right
you'll [ __ ] your pain oh you'll [ __ ]
your pill I know how hard you insulting
son of a [ __ ] if you come at me
Wow peace you up means that you see up
is that something ranking okay
okay give up yeah finish I mean you you
meet ambitious meet now my I don't mean
me no I'll meet you halfway
yeah I'll meet you halfway yeah so
that's all I can guarantee that I'll
meet you halfway
Bryan we cool cuz the ground is coming
at you quick right now the grounds
coming at you Craig right and you might
want them you might want to pull your
pull know what you shoot right your
shirt right pull my pulling rounds
coming at you quick yeah it's coming at
me quick so your mana at this point
right now yeah yeah at this point right
now yeah yeah yes I'm I'm loose right
feel good right so a little hot yeah
right yeah not some caffeine gone okay
right yeah little excited and I'm
feeling strong yeah
and quick yeah right yeah so you might
want it well my one or what grounds
coming at ya I wanna tell me getting me
halfway
are you sure I'm not pulling those shoes
and I'm not pulling I'm you know I'm mr.
Crowley and it's fine it's coming yeah
yeah yeah it's coming real quick you
know I you know what you're drooling out
you [ __ ] drool on your shirt yeah
because I'm cuz I'm foaming at the
[ __ ] mouth no cuz you're a beheading
cow your [ __ ] hand drooling with the
cud and its own tent mill huh you were
trying to suck your own teats and got
beheaded I don't wish you any ill
physically okay so that's why we can't
ever fought all right yep
cuz those eyes cuz you hide them toward
a wall no you know what you know what we
have toward a wall you'd you might want
to yeah well I I put on you into an evil
beast from them from an M night
Shyamalan huh I twist your head
completely around separate all your
joints so that your arms and legs at the
knees go backwards and you'd be like
crawling up like on a wall or something
like that somehow can or until like
that's what I'm gonna feel like I'm
gonna feel light in MAGIX a so and I'm
gonna turn you into a horror movie
villain well until I counter right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]